[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday October
30th you know Hank sometimes people will
accuse me of not being a real nerd
because you know I don't read that much
science fiction I like sports a lot so I
want to thank you for sharing the book I
wrote when I was eight it just isn't
fair because it proves once and for all
that I am definitely a nerd hey can we
just look at the cover art of that book
real quickly okay here we go on the left
there you see me for some reason I'm
kind of a quasi abstract painting and
then over there on the right saying
wimpy wimpy you see a popular person
Hank here's what gets me about wimpy
wimpy guy wimpy wimpy guy is obviously
my eight-year-old understanding of what
a popular person is and that means that
when I was eight I thought that cool was
wearing mismatched plaid pants hiked up
to your solar plexus Hank I was such a
nerd that I thought the Nerds were cool
Hank the reason you couldn't find my box
full of childhood treasures in North
Carolina is that a few years ago mom and
dad sent it to my house where it is kept
safely under lock and key from the
prying eyes of you and your minions that
said I would like to show you some
highlights from my childhood box first
we have this family portrait from 1981
which is a totally normal family
portrait in every single way except that
I clearly need to pee I also have a
report about Thomas Edison I wrote in
third grade Thomas Edison you know he's
famous for inventing the boom box I
don't want to brag Hank but I did get an
a-plus on the report even though I used
the word interesting 11 times that's the
great thing about third grade Hank if
you've got one polysyllabic adjective
everyone thinks you're a genius
heck it's not that I think mom and dad
made me massively unpopular in
elementary school but sometimes I'll
come across something from my childhood
and I'll be like mom and dad what were
you thinking like for instance say I
wanted a sticker album I think that's a
great get me a sticker album for my
birthday by all means sticker albums are
awesome don't make it pink although to
be fair while mom and dad picked out the
album itself I picked out all the
rainbow stickers god I love rainbows
Hank my favorite thing about the pink
stickers album is it's got like a page
for like googly eyed stickers and a page
for my favorite stickers and a page for
scratch and sniff stickers and then it's
got a page for military insignia
stickers weird also in my childhood box
we have this beanie now Hank I wish I
could tell you that mom and dad bought
me this beanie when I was in third
Grainne but the plain fact of the matter
is that I bought it using my own money
when I was a sophomore in high school
Hank the final thing I'd like to show
you unfortunately I don't have I don't
know where it is it may be in North
Carolina actually I'm referring of
course to the only trophy I ever won
Hank it was 1984 and I was still in
t-ball even though everyone else in my
class had moved on to the minor leagues
of Little League I think I think you
might have been spared Little League
baseball so let me give you some quick
terminology t-ball is when instead of
hitting a pitch that's thrown at you you
hit a ball that's just sitting on a tee
so because I was like four years older
than all the other t-ball players I was
relatively good I mean I was terrible
but I was just better than most of the
five year olds and so at the end of the
season they announced the all-star team
and I didn't make the all-star team I
was beat out by a nice kid named Bryce
who was I think four but out of pity
they named me an alternate for the
all-star team and the all-star game
itself was occurring over Thanksgiving
weekend and I didn't want to go see
grandpa in Indiana because I was worried
that Bryce might get injured and my
services might be needed in the all-star
game also I was kind of bummed out
because only the actual all-stars got
trophies the alternates only got like
certificates or something so probably to
convince me to leave town for
Thanksgiving and partly because they're
nice people and they love me mom and dad
had a trophy made for me and the trophy
says John Green 1984 all-star in our
hearts I'm an all-star in their heart
tank and that's the only trophy I ever
won as a child so those are my nerd
credentials Hank I think I've proven my
point I'll see you tomorrow